موقع Voda Baccano op
و 6 كتب في قطاعي الدفاع و Gyeongbuk ، بما في ذلك الرفيق Ro من مهرجان Jangchang للأطفال
وقد التقى
في عام واحد فقط مؤلفو المجلات العلمية في مجال البحث واستراتيجية الجيش الشعبي الكوري
كما أرفقت وحدة العمليات كتاب قراءة روح Hwatong 12.
يجب أن يكون تمرين اختيار الوردة هذا استخدامًا عسكريًا ضدنا مؤخرًا.
التغلب على سياسة الحفاظ على البيئة الأمريكية والرد برد عسكري سريع وقوي
معالجة الرؤوس الحربية النووية لتوفير مزيد من الحماية للقدرة على تنفيذ عمليات الضربات والهجوم الأرضي
فحص النظام وتنفيذ إجراءات العمل النوعي لأغراض مختلفة
ستعطي أرواح دارما المريخية المكشوفة الأوامر وتدفقها
آه
شرير خفيف القلب تم التحقق من شخصيته في الذروة كما أن المكونات التشغيلية لديها مهارات أداء.
إلى عمال كيم في قسم صناعة موغورت في الشارع الرابع وقسم أبحاث علوم الدفاع
هدفنا النهائي هو أن نرتقي كخاضع وأن نذهب مباشرة إلى 7 جرام.
أنت قلت
اشتعلت برائحة نار مشتعلة كانت تتصبب وتتصبب.
لا استطيع